Pickups have a long tradition of a simple
concept: driver up front, cargo in the back.
Today we'll look at the newest developments
in pickups, starting with the Fiat Fullback.Based
on the Mitsubishi L 200, it relies on proven
Japanese high-volume-production technology.
It comes with either rear-wheel or all-wheel
drive.
Under the hood is the newest generation of
Mitsubishi's light-alloy, 4-cylinder, 2.4-liter,
133-kilowatt engine.
We tested it with the 5-speed automatic transmission,
but it comes alternatively with a 6-speed
manual transmission.
A ladder frame with coil springs in front
and leaf springs in back means the Fullback's
ride is not that comfortable.
But off-road, it tackles just about anything.
The all-wheel drive, gear reduction, and a
lockable center differential make you feel
you could go anywhere.
Tester Christof says the Fullback would
be perfect for fetching wood for his fireplace
twice a year.
But it's just too big for the rest of the
time.
Nissan's Navara, with all-wheel drive and
a double cab, costs more than 31,000 euros
in Germany.
And if you equip it as lavishly as our test
car, you quickly get closer to 40,000 euros.
What clearly sets the Navara apart from its
competitors: the double-cab version we're
driving, with two rows of seats, is the only
one with coil springs rather than leaf springs.
That makes it more comfortable to drive than
the competitors, while it's just as competent off-road.
Despite being outfitted with stabilizers,
the axles work together perfectly.
Rear-wheel drive is the Navara's default.
But when needed, you can manually switch to
four-wheel drive.
And the central differential can be locked.
Like the Fiat Fullback, the Navara has a classic
steel frame ensuring that the car doesn't
fall apart even with the roughest treatment,
for example, when towing heavy trailers.
The Navara is the only pickup certified to
tow 3.5 tons.
Spending two years in Australia gave car tester
Moritz an affinity for vehicles like the Nissan Navara.
But while it's prepared for anything in the
Outback, it's not ideal for the big city.
The current Toyota Hilux is already the eighth
generation of this legend among off-road pickups.
For more than 50 years, its been the world's
universal transport.
18 million Hiluxes have been built.
It's hard to be a bigger legend.
And it wouldn't be easy to make the Hilux
any more robust.
But Toyota says the new model's steel-frame
body makes it even more solid.
That's hard to imagine when you know that
millions of Hiluxes have been put to the toughest
tests and still hold up after decades.
You'd think there would be nothing left to
improve.
And subjectively, it's not easy to tell.
The Hilux is like a fortress.
The engine pulls and the wheels rumble as
they always have.
The price for the Hilux with all-wheel drive
and a double cabin begins at almost 35,000 euros.
But if you want one as nice as our test car,
you'll be pushing 40,000 euros here, too.
Jochen Frerichs says the Hilux has been
THE construction-site vehicle all over the
world for almost 50 years.
It's robust through and through.
Jochen's only criticism?
The 150-horsepower engine is a bit weak and
not certified to pull more than 3.2 tons.
Otherwise, this is the most iconic pickup
of all.
There's a difference between the three pickups.
All of them climb steep grades effortlessly.
But downhill is a different matter.
Only the Toyota and the Nissan have electronic
hill descent control to help them move down
gravel roads safely.
They all have in common the little-boy thrill
you get when taking the driver's seat.
All three feel like they were made for playing
in that great big sandbox, the world.
The open beds offer some practical advantages.
But hardly anyone would use them regularly,
except on the job at construction sites and
the like.
These trucks are big, cumbersome fuel-guzzlers.
In sum: We see the disadvantages but love
these vehicles anyway for being so different.
And after a hard day's work, what could beat
a few beers at a tailgate party?